[Music]
we have breaking news we will be posting
the rest of Brett's interview with
secretary azar on our Fox News special
report website but we have breaking news
president Trump has just tweeted I am
pleased to announce that effective for 9
18 April 9th Ambassador John Bolton will
be my new national security adviser I am
very thankful for the service of general
HR McMaster who has done an outstanding
job and will always remain my friend
there will be an official contact
handover on 4 9 April 9th so the
president announcing that HR McMaster
general McMaster is out as his national
security advisor and former ambassador
John Bolton a Fox News contributor is in
as the national security adviser I think
it's fair to say let me first bring in
the panel Byron York from the Washington
Examiner Susan page of USA Today and
Jonathan Swan of Axios I think it's fair
to say that this while the timing may be
a bit of a surprise the fact that
McMaster was gonna be out sooner
probably rather than later is maybe a
surprise this the timing of it Jonathan
you've been covering this and the
question as to whether or not McMaster
is out and when he was going to be out
and who the replacement was going to be
your thoughts well I'll tell you this is
shocked people inside the building again
it's the timing of it they there was an
assumption that at some point he was
going to remove HR McMaster they never
formed a personal chemistry he never
worked out how to brief the President
and this appointment of John Bolton this
is not about ideology this is not about
ideology John Bolton is as
interventionist and hawkish as they come
and this is about personal chemistry
with the President of the United States
he thinks he's strong he sees him on
television he likes him and and again HR
McMaster never really gelled with this
president it didn't become as toxic as
it did with Rex Tillerson the Secretary
of State but he was seen as a dead man
walking for months inside the White
House all right I want to talk a little
bit more about this but general McMaster
has just issued a statement in response
to the statement from president
McMaster says after 34 years of service
to our nation I am requesting retirement
from the US Army affected this summer
after which I will leave public service
throughout my career it has been my
greatest privilege to serve alongside
extraordinary service members and
dedicated civilians I am thankful to
president Donald J Trump for the
opportunity to serve him and our nation
as a National Security Advisor I am
grateful for the friendship and
opportunity of the members of the
National Security Council who worked
together to provide the president with
the best options to protect and advance
our national interests I'm especially
proud to have served alongside the men
and women of the National Security
Council staff who established a strong
foundation for protecting the American
people promoting American prosperity
achieving peace through strength and
advancing American influence I know that
these Patriots will continue to serve
our president and our nation with
distinction before I bring in Susan and
Byron Jonathan at this the reason I
think we're a little bit surprises there
was a story on the front page I believe
it was the Washington Post last week
that said McMaster was out and over on
Friday McMaster and Kelly said no he's
not out that he's there you know it's a
dreaded vote of confidence so why give
them the vote of confidence and then
less than a week later pulled the rug
out because the honest truth is they
didn't know the timing they didn't know
the timing and I'll tell you because I
was one of those reporters on Thursday
that reached out to the White House and
the reason the Washington Post could run
that story
was the White House stopped pushing back
on Thursday last week the White House
stopped leaning in to aggressively
opposing reporters who were saying you
know I'm hearing McMaster is out they
suddenly said basically behind the
scenes we're not really gonna wave you
off that in a very aggressive way the
next morning you can't you know you
can't completely say the guy's gone
while he's still in the job so they had
to walk this very awkward tightrope
knowing full well that the president of
United States wanted a new national
security adviser not knowing who that
person would be or when he was going to
make the decision and I'll just tell you
this afternoon I was getting calls from
the White House the press team was
chaotic running around it seems to me
like they were caught a little bit
off-guard by what happened today
Susan I mean there two aspects of this
that are interesting one obviously is
McMaster his service why he didn't gel
with the president and then the
appointment of John Bolton and what that
says about the president's foreign
policy going forward and we got to
remember we're now less than two months
away if it goes as planned from a summit
with Kim jong-un the leader of North
Korea and the president is going to have
a completely new well except for the
defense secretary national security team
a new Secretary of State Mike Pompeo a
new national security adviser in John
Bolton and we also need to remember at
mcmaster was brought in after the
precipitous and sudden firing after
three weeks of Michael Flynn as national
security adviser first few thoughts of
McMaster what he did right what he did
wrong well as we've said he wasn't a
good fit kind of hidden personality ways
with with the president although Bolton
wasn't either when they first met
remember Bolton was up for a job and
went and met with the president and did
not immediately click with him with him
either you know this is the reason this
is shocking but not surprising not
surprising because we knew McMaster was
having trouble it's shocking because of
the timing that you mentioned the spring
we're supposed to have a meeting with
the North Korean leader we may not have
a Secretary of State we don't know that
micro-pay will be confirmed by the time
the North Korean meeting takes place if
it takes place on time now of course the
National Security Advisor can work at
the president's discretion doesn't
require confirmation so so he can start
in April as they've said but this is a
time when we got these huge foreign
policy challenges we know that the State
Department has not staffed up in the way
it traditionally has been staffed up
with experts and now the president will
have this new team that will take
presumably at least some time to find
their footing well and as I'm thinking
as you're talking we're all obviously
reacting in real-time here the president
surprised his foreign policy team when
he had his phone call with Vladimir
Putin this week not only congratulating
him on his victory but perhaps more
consequentially talking about having a
meeting in the not-too-distant future
and they're not supposed to be in the
same city for one of these huge
multilateral meetings until next
November so conceivably they could on
the fly be having to deal with a Kim
jong-un summit and a Vladimir Putin's on
them
and meanwhile we've started a trade war
with China so if you want to talk about
a word we don't know that we have a
trade war with them but we've it's
possible it's a world in some turmoil
that's for sure
you know it is interesting Biron about
john bolton who's a respected member of
the fox news team as a contributor
because I do know the president was
considering him last when he first came
in and in December during the transition
December of 2016 and one of the concerns
was the fact that he was very aggressive
that he was a neoconservative in the
sense of wanting to confront other
countries of course the president ran on
the idea of avoiding those kinds of
international entanglements I think you
can want to talk about one policy in
particular in the sense that McMaster I
think was a guy who told the president
he couldn't do stuff particularly
concerning the Iran nuclear deal it has
to be recertified every three months so
it's come up I mean four times so far
and the president wants to get out of it
and they said no no you can't do that
maybe you should kind of pull out a
little bit or issue an ultimatum or get
some other people to try to get them on
board there's other things you can do
meanwhile our commitment to it stands
now he sees john bolton on television
talking about the Iran nuclear deal he
seasoned to Bolton on television taking
a very hard line toward North Korea so
he calls him up he it's not like they
haven't talked all year they have been
talking at various times so I think he
feels that he wants that kind of kind of
voice also this is a position that
doesn't have to be confirmed by the
Senate and George W Bush when he made
Bolton the UN Ambassador had to do it
through recess appointment because Rand
Paul and a few other members of the US
Senate just said it would not happen so
it had to be if you're gonna appoint
Bolton had to be in a non confirmed
position all right panels stand by we're
going to continue this conversation in a
moment